if you're flying out this week or maybe
expecting family in town the airlines
are reporting they are ready for the
busy holiday travel period thank you so
much for staying with us here at 4 30.
I'm Christian casras I'm Kirsten Joyce
now this is despite some 45 000 flights
being canceled over the summer we
reached out to find out what changes
Airlines have made to make the
experience better
for travelers the summer was a low point
in terms of getting around with minimal
stress one out of every four flights
delayed tens of thousands canceled the
good news things seem to be getting
better I am cautiously optimistic that
we're not going to see the same type of
Airline meltdown that we saw this past
summer Scott Keyes of Scott's cheap
flights makes it his business to know
what's happening within the industry
domestic airlines are hoping for a
smooth Thanksgiving travel week they've
adjusted schedules and hiring needs to
meet current flight demand I reached out
to find out exactly what changes have
been made Southwest responded in part by
saying quote to support operational
performance and reliability Southwest
hired more than 15 700 new employees
this year we've taken steps to bolster
flexibility and options for customers
including flight credits that never
expire Airlines for America which
lobbies for Delta United and American
says in part quote there are 10 percent
more pilots working for A4 4A carriers
now than pre-pandemic and the president
and CEO of Frontier Airlines Barry
Biffle has this recommendation for
travelers you should pack a little
patience and make sure that you show up
a little bit early but I do expect that
the Staffing levels should should be
there across the the chain I know TSA
Staffing's gotten there I know all of
our business partners have been working
on their Staffing so we expect to have
have smoother operations than we've had
in the past expect flights to be full
because the number of planes in the sky
is still down about 15 to 20 percent
compared to 2019. don't expect a whole
lot of Elbow Room or that empty middle
seat especially over the holiday period
because it's likely that on most flights
every single seat is going to be taken
and for those who haven't traveled in a
while the airport's going to be busier
than you may recall larger crowds
potentially longer wait times for
everything from parking to check-in
security screening to Food Services so
plan ahead and give yourself some extra
time we did check Reed International
Airport today good news no flight
cancellations hopefully no problems come
Wednesday as it will be the busiest
between the hours of noon and six
Saturday and Sunday of course we'll be
busy as Travelers return home